u.n figure show china was the largest
recipient of new foreign direct
investment in 2020
overtaking the us for the first time the
chinese economy brought in 163 billion
dollars in investment as the coronavirus
outbreak
spread across the world that compares to
the 134
billion attracted by the united states
well on that let's speak to our
correspondents in frankfurt ashitosh
pandey
ashitosh how has china managed to
leapfrog the us
like this
well it's to do with the performance on
the pandemic front uh china managed to
deal with the pandemic better than the
u.s
it got the economy running uh fairly
quickly and that's the reason why
emerged as one of the uh in fact the
only major economy to
register positive growth us on the other
hand has struggled to control the
pandemic and
and actually has seen a slump in its
output
and and that's that's also the case in
europe here and
and investments in europe have also
slumber by two-thirds
uh and and clearly at this point uh
companies are very of committing capital
abroad
given the uncertainty around
trade relations between the u.s and
china are expected to be on the agenda
when
chinese president xi jinping speaks at
the virtual
davos agenda event a bit later on what
sort of tone are we expecting him to
strike
well he's certainly going to reach out
to the biden administration
and try and rebuild and restore those
ties which have actually been broken
increasingly strained under president
from president trump
that's one of the things uh he's going
to talk about uh china's credentials on
as far as fighting with climate change
is concerned where he's pledged
zero uh emission uh uh by 2050
uh rather 2060 and then he's also going
to talk about uh
globalization openness like he did in
2017 uh
davos meeting but many are actually
skeptical and
would like to take uh whatever he says
with a pinch of salt because the last
time he spoke about glo
uh he defended trade wars he actually
initiated one against australia
a few years down the line and also he
spoke about openness but he went on
unfairly propping up
uh state-owned enterprises uh and and
clearly there was no
openness as far as investments are
concerned so
yes uh these are the new few talking
points that people are going to look out
for
could be very different this time round
ashitosh pandey thanks for joining us